bienvenue à chartres où des graffeurs
ont investi le service pédiatrique de
l'hôpital chartrain je vais de suite à
la rencontre de charles alias lapin kg
m'expliquer cette aventure formidable
qui a redonné du sourire dans les coeurs
de ses enfants en quête de réconfort
yoyo salut charles mondry alias lapin le
graffiti
qu'est ce que c'est le graffiti c'est
une activité qui se passe à l'extérieur
généralement sur des trains sur des murs
chacun sa petite définition le stic de
deux lapins alors c'est quoi ça va être
je te dirai illustratif psychédélique
poste psychédélique néo-pop entendions
voilà on a parlé de lapin ici à
l'atelier monde aussi parler de vos
oeuvres à l'extérieur le street art moi
j'ai différentes pratiques et depuis une
dizaine d'années je travaille beaucoup
en milieu médico socio éducatif on a
fait un projet à l'hôpital de chartres
et ben on peut aller découvrir ça sur
place allez je vous je suis c'est parti
ok
c
[Musique]
bonjour aline bonjour donc vous êtes
éducatrice au pôle enfant au service
pédiatrique ici à l'hôpital
donc vous avez participé un peu aux
oeuvres devant son public on a accueilli
les graffeurs il ya quelques années pour
qu'il vienne décorée certaines parties
du service de pédiatrie ça a vraiment
permis d'apporter beaucoup de gaieté de
bien-être aux enfants comme aux familles
et aux soignants aussi et au cours de
ces moments où les graffeurs sont venus
ils ont fait participer les enfants qui
étaient présents sur le service ce
jour-là ils ont fait participer les
soignants donc ça a été un moment très
agréable et donc il ya un réel impact au
final sur les enfants quand ils arrivent
par exemple en salles d'attentes tout à
fait quand il arrive sur le service la
première salle qu'on voie en entrant sur
le service de pédiatrie ça fait comme un
aquarium avec des requins début des
poissons ça permet aux enfants de voir
leurs hospitalisations un petit peu
différemment alors c'est cet autre
convoi derrière il n'y a pas que vous
qui avez pas non pas du tout il ya
arsène turpin et à mad dog aussi il ya
participé et les deux ont fait un autre
mur qu'on va aller voir tout de suite on
va les vérifier admin merci beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà c'est bonjour
bonne forme cette oeuvre ben on vous l'a
doit à vous comment vous avez réagi
quand vous a justement invités à venir
peindre les murs ici pour le projet en
fait j'étais super heureux parce que
l'hôpital ici moi j'ai une histoire
perso avec ma mère qui est décédée ici
du coup quand on m'a dit que c'était
pour les enfants que c'était des enfants
qui avaient des maladies plus ou moins
graves
nous pour nous c'était l'occasion la
sauce de dédramatiser l'hospitalisation
pour les enfants en fait de ramener de
la couleur
du coup les a fait participer à votre
stratégie artistique c'était les mignons
ouais enfin c'est le truc qui était à
l'époque à la mode donc on est parti là
dessus c'est unisexe en fait mais là les
mignons ils ont eu leur efficacité parce
que vous avez eu une anecdote par
rapport à une petite fille et voilà il
ya une petite fille qui est rentré dans
la chambre qui a voulu serrer le mignon
dans les bras donc c'est cool c'est à
dire comment nous on a réussi notre
objectif quoi c'est que l'enfant pense à
autre chose en fait